字幕: Moe Shoji
校正: Kazunori Akashi
（Zombie Zoo Keeper）
Zombie Zoo Keeperです
怖いキャラが大好きな８歳です
夏休みにお母さんと一緒に
NFTを始めました
ピクセルアートの
マス目に沿って作るので
アイロンビーズみたいで楽しいです
OpenSeaに作品を上げたことで
世界中の人が買ってくれて
びっくりしました
最初はポケモンカードが買えて
うれしかったです
でもどんどん売れるごとに
大ごとになっていき
毎週 家にテレビの人が
来るようになりました
そして世界的DJの
スティーブ青木さんが
買ってくれたときは
びっくりしました
彼は僕の才能を
とてもほめてくれました
僕は絵がうまくないと
思っていたけど
自分のスタイルで描くと
受け入れられました
200近くの作品を上げ
多くの人に買ってもらいました
僕が学んだことが３つあります
１つ目
アートで有名になったり
お金を稼ぐのに
ラッキーが大事だってこと
どんなにがんばっても成功はしません
時代に恵まれていることなど
ラッキーじゃないと
うまくいかないことです
僕はNFTが始まったばかりの
タイミングで
作品を作ることができました
２つ目
早く始めればライバルが少ないことです
大人になったら
たくさんのライバルができます
でも 小学生で
画家としてやっている人は
少なかったので
人気になりました
３つ目
お金は怖くない
最初はお金が怖いと思いました
でも 大切に扱っていれば
怖くないことです
僕が今稼いだお金は
大学のお金に使い
そのために勉強もします
僕は小学生にして
マリオのボーナスステージみたいな
場所にいます
簡単には ずっとこんな風に
お金を稼げないかもしれません
それでも 今ファンの人に
感謝して頑張ります
僕が将来何になるかはわかりませんが
見守ってください
ピンクだったらかわいいなと思った
あとピンクの方が
実は売れてんですよ
（草野絵美）本当に彼は―
見た通りには描けないけど
その見たものを こう
彼の想像の中で補っていって
面白い形にアレンジするのが
すごく上手だなと思っています
ただ どのお子さんもきっと
なんか大人にはない視点を
持っていたりとか
何かそれぞれの個性があると思うので
たぶんこの話をしている時は
目がキラキラしてるとか
この工作の この作業をしている時は
ものすごい集中しているなみたいなことが
あると思うんですけど
そういったフロー状態になっている
お子さんの瞬間を見つけて
それがきっとたぶん―
鍵になるかなと思うので
そういうところに注目してあげて
みんなそういう何か表現をしていたら
それをまたインターネットとかに
NFTに限ったことじゃないんですけど
作品を発信してみるっていうのは
親子にとっても
すごく楽しい体験になると思うので
ぜひみなさんも
なにか発信してみてくださいって思います
発信の方法は―
そうですね
本当に人によって
さまざまだと思うんですけど
ソーシャルメディアを
それ用に作って
インスタに上げるとか
YouTubeに上げるとか
そんなことでもいいと思いますし
こうやってOpenSeaっていう
マーケットプレイスで
NFT化して 実際に売買を
体験してもらうってことも
いいと思います
でも そうですね
やり方を調べれば
こう 必ず見つけられるので
まずは やり方を調べてみるのが
いいかなと思います
あとはもう失敗を恐れずに
とにかく世に出してないと
やっぱり何か なかったことと
一緒になってしまうのかなと思っていて
私自身も子供の頃いっぱいパソコンで
絵を描いていたんですけど
それが今 全部残ってないんですよね
データとしてどこかに
バックアップしておけばよかったんですけど
そういう発想が
その時はなかったんで
全部残ってなくて
それは寂しいなと思うので
それがブロックチェーンに
刻まれるっていうのは
本当にロマンチックなことだなと思います
普段から―
いろんなニュースを見聞きするときに
これはもしかして
子どもの可能性を伸ばす
何かヒントになるかなっていう視点を
持って見ると
なんかすべてが
教育的な機会に感じることができる
っていうのがありますね
だからたまたま
本当にNFTが いま黎明期で
彼の表現と何かを作って
物を売るっていう体験に
すごく結びついたのが
本当に良かったなと思うので
まずはお父さんとお母さんも自分で
何かやってみるのがいいと思います
私も NFT作品を出す前に
自分の作品を１回出して売るっていう
経験をしていたので
ただ自分が作品を作ったときは
かなり考え込んでしまって
ゆっくりゆっくり作って
完璧なのができたから
出そうみたいな
そういう感覚があったんですけど
息子は結構バンバン
躊躇なく発表していったので
それはすごい面白かったなというか
自分が創作する上でも
かなり勇気づけられました
親御さん自体が
こうリテラシーを高く持って
情報をいろいろ精査するというのは
すごく大事なのかなと思います
彼が最初は絵にあんまり
自信がないってことを話してたんですけど
世界で作品を発信して
彼ならではの―
Zombie Zoo Keeperならではの
持ち味というか
物事の捉え方みたいなところを
すごく評価していただいて
彼自身にもすごく自信になったし
それがアーティストとしても
作家性につながっていったのかなと思います
将来これからアーティストになるにしても
それ以外の職種に就くにしても
ここで作品を作って
自分でこれだけお金も稼いで
世界の人がいろいろ
喜んでくれたりとかして
それを８才という歳で体験できたのは
これからの将来の糧に
なるかなと思います
子どもの頃に考えてたことを
思い出して
それがまた大人になったときの
クリエイティブなヒントになればなと思います
この Zombie Zoo Keeper
NFT作品の発信が
いつまでも続くかどうかは
わからないんですけど
彼が楽しいって思える限り
サポートしていきたいなと思います